hours for bill hummertrout this is a
scam there's no one in bill's life that
would send him flowers
it's true something's up i can't believe
i'm about to say this but bill
tell us all about yourself let's start
with my whole family history
i was abandoned at a playground as an
infant and here i am
oh that was the whole thing well sad but
easier than remembering a bunch of names
okay so bill do you have a real job or
i'm the third in a lot of marriages i
got a nice soft face so i don't
intimidate the husbands hmm
strange the random person i hired off
the streets of brooklyn was a weirdo
what
hmm nothing he's trying to distract us
oh if i were trying to distract you i
would have sent you the pizza this is
your doing you and your male prostitute
bill is not a male prostitute i don't
think
hey over here losers i got to say bill
your gina impression was spot-on i'm
very good at role play
and i'm super comfortable wearing masks
right forgot you were maybe a male
prostitute i was definitely a male
prostitute but i don't do that
profession anymore now
i sell vitamin supplements i made 90 000
this year alone working out of the
comfort of my own home uh-huh how did i
do it
nutriboom right and the good news is you
can do it too okay bill this is clearly
a pyramid scheme we're not interested
thanks for coming back bill i really
needed a teammate hey man
you're paying no you can take the wig
off if you want
whatever you want man you're paying
cause you stop saying that bill it's
making me a little uncomfortable all
right man it's your money
that's the same thing hey let me ask you
this how would you like to be your own
boss
not now bill thanks bud we will always
be best friends
you hear that bill nobody likes you i
knew i couldn't trust you rosa that's
what i was gonna double-cross you with
bill that's right he didn't really die
hey guys you really thought i'd miss
this year's heist no way
i'm part of the squad this is impossible
we'll never get him there so you guys
need help moving a body thank god oh
bill's part of the squad
i mean assuming i am part of the squad
finally i have somewhere to live what
meet me in the alley next to my shopping
cart it's the one with all the cans but
wait what about the lieutenant's exam
aren't you supposed to be taking it
right now
hell no i took that thing weeks ago and
i passed i'm already a lieutenant
you are that's incredible lieutenant
jeffords this is amazing i'm so proud of
you terry
all right you've overstepped nabil yeah
it's weird you're here bill this is
written in white ink on white paper
they do it that way so you can't read it
well i did read it and i'm canceling the
contract
canceling it was that easy to get out
would i be here scamming my closest
friends we're your closest friends
what whatever i'm not accepting the
shipment the infiniti gems will be
guarded by a ferocious and daunting
sentry
hey best friends we're not your best
friends bill you don't get to decide
that
so bill will hide the gems in his
pockets you're really gonna have to root
around in there
i dried my jeans so they're extra tight
you were right amy i should have got a
safe sorry everyone let the heist begin
i told you i'll always be one step ahead
of you you can't surprise me
you're boring you know what spices up a
relationship co-owning a multi-tiered
marketing ignore him come on
just please uncuff me please you got a
man i've never treated you like a
prostitute
you just did touche all right how about
this i will buy
double the amount of supplements that
boyle did eight thousand dollars what he
gave you four grand
oh all right fine i'm in he didn't give
it to me he invested it in his future
and you can too i already agreed to it
you don't have to keep selling me
sorry the script we're given anticipates
a lot more resistance okay so let's get
the paperwork started
first things first you are not allowed
to have any of this reviewed by an
attorney yeah this seems bad
oh a lot of infighting not too late to
ditch amy and team up with this
pussycat burglar please boyle your only
value was you had a doppelganger which
no longer matters since
bill died in that accident it can still
be useful without bill
all of my belongings that you'll need
are in this suitcase
why is it vibrating is your cell phone
in here no i'm sure it's not a sex toy
that's why the number of belly buttons i
have
is two one zero ah
why would he have swallowed the gems
well a photograph of cheddar was
featured on
chunky pups and instagram account for
overweight pets a top comment called him
a thick king kevin and i put him on a
diet and i suppose
he got hungry enough to mistake the gems
for food this is why you don't team up
with a dog
it's better than teaming up with bill
like you do every year bill is a human
he is able to use more than just his
mouth not if you don't want me to he'll
stop chiming in i'm just saying i'm not
that different than a dog
i'm not helping all right the heist will
pick up where we left off there are six
hours remaining and three teams left the
now
sterilized infinititude gems will be
placed back into the care of bill
oh wow bill looks like he had a rough
four months it was actually a great
three months and then one really bad one
okay but you're here and you're happier
than ever i don't know why you think
that
let the high stream begin the
infinititude gems will go back
to bill whose life seems to have
unraveled even further tough march for
you there bud
yeah just a heads up i sold my pants
with the pocket so i'll be putting the
gems
in my undies this time no i'll give him
a fanny pack can i keep it
this could be just what i need to turn
my life around yeah belt you can keep
the panty back i don't have to do
anything for it do i
because i will if you ask i'll do
anything even
what's that supposed to represent no one
answer that
you